ON THE SHOW A MAN WHO I
INTERVIEWED ON MARCH 1ST. AND
HERE WE ARE IN THE THE
THE END OF THE FIRST WEEK OF
APRIL IN OUR CALENDAR YEAR.
AND HE IS NOW A NATIONAL
CHAMPION HEAD COACH OF BAYLOR
BASKETBALL. HE IS SCOTT DREW
COACH DRU. THANKS FOR CALLING
IN TO THE SHOW. WELL, THANKS
FOR HAVING ME BACK ON. THANKS
FOR YOUR ADVICE ON MARCH 1ST.
IT WORKS.
YES. A LOT OF PEOPLE CALLING
YOU ON MARCH 1ST EVERY YEAR I
BET SO I BET SO WE CALL THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CALL THAT
COACH WE CALL IT THE RICH
BUMP WE'VE HAD PEOPLE ON THIS
SHOW WHO HAVE WON OSCARS
AFTER BEING ON THIS SHOW AND
M. HE'S BEING OUT IT DOESN'T
IT DOESN'T MATTER. IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF IT'S IMMEDIATE OR
LONG-TERM. WE JUST TAKE
CREDIT FOR IT. SO I
APPRECIATE YOU TACITLY GIVING
SOME TO US TO APPRECIATE THE
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU GUYS DO
JIMMER AND AND OBVIOUSLY
GREATLY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU
AND YOUR GUYS HAVE DONE AND
WHAT THEY WHAT YOU DID IF I
HAD TOLD YOU THAT
THE DAY THAT YOU WERE HIRED
AT BAYLOR AND EVERYTHING THAT
WAS GOING ON IN THE PROGRAM
THAT YOUR VISION WOULD BE
EVENTUALLY REALIZED IN 2021.
YOU WOULD HAVE SAID WHAT ON
THAT DAY COACH, IT'S GONNA
TAKE THAT LONG RIGHT? WELL,
YOU'RE YOUNG. YOU'RE
PROBABLY NOT.
YOU KNOW, I TELL YOU WHAT,
WE HAD SO MUCH SUCCESS. SO IN
2010, YOU GO TO THE ELITE
EIGHT YOUR ROOSTER THE
NATIONAL CHAMPION. YOU'RE
LIKE MAN, WE COULD HAVE WON A
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP.
SHOULD WE EVEN DO IT RIGHT
AND IN 2012 USED TO KENTUCKY
IN THE ELITE 8 THEY WON A
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP AND
YOU'RE LIKE WE'RE RIGHT THERE
AND THEN AND THEN IT TAKES
SOME TIME TO GET BACK TO A
CHANCE TO PLAY FOR A FINAL
FOUR AND THEN THEN YOU BREAK
THROUGH AND I TELL YOU WHAT
IT DOES IS IT DOES TEACH YOU
TO APPRECIATE IT THAT MUCH
MORE BECAUSE WHEN YOUR
CLOTHES AND DON'T GET
SOMETHING AND THEN IT COMES
LATER YOU REALLY YOU REALLY
KNOW. IT'S A BLESSING AND AND
THAT'S WHERE GOD'S PLANS
ALWAYS BEST AND
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU GET THERE
YOU WANT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF GREAT TEAMS
PROGRAMS COACHES THE NEVER
GET TO A FINAL FOUR OR WIN IT
ALL AND HATS OFF TO OUR
PLAYERS THAT REALLY HELPED
BRING IT HOME. AND SO LET'S
LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT. AND
WHAT DID YOU TELL YOUR TEAM
PRIOR TO THE NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME? WHAT DID
YOU WHAT DID YOU SAY I GUESS
IN THAT HOOSIERS MOMENT MAYBE
IN THE LOCKER ROOM THERE AND
STATE OF INDIANA WHERE
EVERYBODY'S GATHERED. WE ALL
KNOW THAT GONZAGA HAD HISTORY
ITALY EVERYBODY CERTAINLY ON
THIS SHOW AND EVERYBODY IN
THE MEDIA WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE BIG FINISH OF THE GAME
AFTER YOUR VICTORY AGAINST
HOUSTON. YOUR BLOWOUT WIN.
EVERYONE WAS TALKING ABOUT
GONZAGA AND HOW MARK FEW
WOULD GET HIS GUYS UP. WHAT
DID YOU SAY TO YOUR TEAM IN
THAT LOCKER ROOM WHAT TO BE
HONEST WITH BY THE TIME WE
GOT TO THAT LOCKER. I THOUGHT
OUR GUYS WERE PREPARED AND
THEY DESERVE THE CREDIT FROM
WE YOU'RE GIVEN ONCE YOU
ADVANCE EACH ROUND A COUPLE
DAYS OF PRACTICE AND OUR TEAM
REALLY DONE AFTER THOSE
COUPLE DAYS OF PRACTICE EACH
WEEK AND WE KEPT IMPROVEMENT.
WE KEPT GETTING BETTER AND WE
NEEDED TO COMING OFF THAT
THREE-WEEK PAUSE. SO TO ME
EVERY BATTLE IS WON BEFORE
IT'S FOUGHT AND EVERYONE
KNOWS SUN TZU'S THE ART OF
WAR BUT IT'S SO TRUE. THERE'S
NO MAGICAL SPEECH OR PILL.
NO ADVILS GOING TO GET YOU
THAT VICTORY RIGHT BEFORE YOU
WALK OUT NOW, OBVIOUSLY, I'M
AN ENERGETIC PERSON. YES, AND
I'M GOING TO TRY I'M
GONNA TRY TO MAKE SURE
MOTIVATED BUT THAT BATTLE WAS
WON IN THAT WEEK OF PRACTICE
LEADING UP TO IT THEIR
PREPARATION AND ALL THE FILM
SESSIONS LEADING UP TO IT.
AND THEN THE ONE THING THAT
THAT WAS GREAT
IS I THOUGHT THEY UNDERSTOOD
TWO THINGS ONE HOW MUCH THEY
WERE FAMILY CARED ABOUT THEM
LOVED THEM AND THEY HAD A
CHANCE TO MAKE HISTORY BEING
THE BEING THE FIRST THEY WERE
BASKETBALL TEAM TO WIN A
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP. THEY
ALSO UNDERSTOOD HISTORY TO BE
THE
SECOND SCHOOL IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS TO WIN A NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP IN THE FIRST ONE
THEY DID A MOVIE ON IN 1966.
SO I MEAN THEY KNEW HOW BIG
THIS OPPORTUNITY WAS AND THEY
KNEW YOU CAN'T JUST SAY WELL,
YOU KNOW WHAT IN THE FUTURE
WE'LL GET BACK BECAUSE EVERY
YEARS DIFFERENT AND JERRY
COLANGELO ACTUALLY HAD A
RECORDED MESSAGE THAT WAS
TREMENDOUS JUST BRINGING THAT
THAT POINT HOME TO HIM JUST
YOU GOT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THESE OPPORTUNITIES AND
CREDIT OUR GUYS FOR BEING
LOCKED IN WE REALLY REALLY
EACH WEEK. I THOUGHT GOT
BETTER AND PLAYED BETTER AND
AND THAT'S A TRIBUTE TO OUR
PLAYERS. SO YOU PLAYED A
RECORDING FROM JERRY
COLANGELO FOR THE TEAM BEFORE
THEY WENT OUT THAT WAS PART
OF THE PREGAME. NO, NO THAT
WAS DONE EARLIER. WE DO LIKE
ONE THING BEAUTIFUL ABOUT THE
BUBBLE IS THERE ARE MANY
DISTRACTIONS RIGHT BESIDES
OUR GUYS DOING HOMEWORK AND
THEN GET REALLY GOOD AT YOUR
NECK FOR AND CORNHOLES. WE
THE FILM SESSIONS AND TALK
TEAM TIME OPPORTUNITIES WHERE
WE COULD REALLY BOND GROW
APPRECIATE ONE ANOTHER LEARN
MORE ABOUT ONE ANOTHER AND
THEN AND THEN OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE ZOOM AND VIDEO
NOWADAYS YOU CAN YOU CAN HAVE
A TON OF GUEST SPEAKERS AND
TONY DUNGY OFFERED A GREAT
MESSAGE TO OUR TEAM AS WELL
AND APPRECIATIVE THE GUYS
THAT COMMUNICATED WITH OUR
GUYS SCOTT DREW HERE ON THE
RICH EYES AND SHOW ONE THING
THAT I DEFINITELY NOTICED
ABOUT YOUR TEAM THAT
HE YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY LEARNED
IN MARCH MADNESS IF THEY
HADN'T FOLLOWED YOUR TEAM
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR SCOTT IS
JUST HOW TIRELESS YOUR TEAM
IS. I MEAN TIRELESS ON EVERY
POSSESSION THERE WAS NEVER A
LET-UP NEVER WHETHER IT'S
CRASHING THE BOARDS OR
SWITCHING ON DEFENSE OR USING
A TRANSITION OPPORTUNITY TO
YOUR ADVANTAGE TO MAKING THE
OPEN SHOT WERE HOW DO YOU
HOW DO YOU COACH THAT? HOW DO
YOU HOW DO YOU FOSTER
SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND OR
RECRUIT FOR IT? BECAUSE IT
SEEMS LIKE THERE IS A LIKE -
OF EVERYBODY ON YOUR TEAM
GREAT QUESTION. SO THE FIRST
THING IS THE STAFF DESERVES A
LOT OF CREDIT FOR RECRUITING
THAT BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE
RIGHT PEOPLE ON THE BUS AND
THE SECOND PART IS OUR STAFF.
I THINK OUR ASSISTANT COACHES
DO A GREAT JOB OR STRENGTH
COACH OR TRAINER AND MAKING
SURE THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
KEEP IMPROVING AND GETTING
BETTER EACH AND EVERY DAY.
DAY OF PRACTICE
THROUGHOUT THEEAR AND THEN
THE PLAYERS DESERVE A LOT OF
THE CREDIT FOR THEIR HARD
WORK TIME AND SACRIFICE
BECAUSE EVERYBODY PRACTICES
THE SAME AMOUNT OF TIME
BECAUSE THE NCAA LIMITATIONS
WHERE YOU GET BETTER ARE
THOSE PEOPLE THAT COME BACK
IN THE GYM THERE THERE EARLY
IN THE MORNING. THEY'RE IN
THEIR EARLY LATE AT NIGHT. WE
GOT GUYS THAT JUST THEIR GYM
RATS AND THEY LOVE TO BE IN
THERE WITH YOUR TEAMMATES
IRON SHARPENS IRON. THEY LOVE
GET BETTER. AND SO THEY'RE
THE ONES PUTTING IN THE WORK
WITH THAT ONE KEY. I THINK TO
OUR SUCCESS WAS OUR STARTING
ROTATION.
ROTATION TO WE HAVE A LOT OF
DEPTH ON OUR TEAM AND WHEN
YOU'RE WHEN YOU'RE PLAYING
WHEN PEOPLE GO TO THE BENCH,
THERE'S USUALLY A DROP OFF WE
GO TO THE BENCH AND A LOT OF
TIMES WE GET BETTER BECAUSE
AS YOU KNOW EACH AND EVERY
NIGHT'S NOT GOING TO BE YOUR
NIGHT SHOOTING WISE AND YOU
GOT TO HAVE MULTIPLE PEOPLE
THAT CAN GET YOU 20 POINTS IN
THAT EIGHT MEN ROTATION THAT
WE PUT IN THAT'S A STARTING
ROTATION IN OUR MIND AND
THOSE THAT ALLOWS YOU TO PLAY
HARDER WHEN YOU'RE IN BECAUSE
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU GO TO THE
TEAM, YOU DON'T HAVE TO SAVE
YOURSELF. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
CONSERVE OR TAKE PLACE OFF TO
GO EXTENDED TIME BECAUSE YOU
CAN GIVE EVERYTHING KNOWING
SOMEONE'S GOT YOUR BACK WHEN
THEY COME IN. WAS THERE A
POINT IN THE GAME ON MONDAY
NIGHT COACH WHERE YOU'RE LIKE,
OH GOSH, THIS THIS, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS EXACTLY THE WAY I
WANTED IT TO PLAY OUT.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU'RE A COACH AND
YOU CAN YOU'RE ALWAYS LOOKING
FOR THAT TRAP DOOR. YOU'RE
ALWAYS LOOKING TO MAKE SURE
THAT NOBODY ALREADY READS
THEIR NEWSPAPER CLIPPINGS.
JUST FIVE TEN MINUTES IN THE
AIR. I MEAN, YOU'RE UP 11:1
FIRST TV TIMEOUT 29TH.
10, YOU KNOW A 9-2 RUN THROWN
ON YOU, BUT YOU'RE STILL UP
BY 10 AND THEN YOUR GUYS
RESPOND WITH DAMN NEAR A 10-0
RUN ITSELF WHEN GONZAGA CUTS
IT TO NINE AT WHAT POINT DID
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE MAYBE HAVE
DAWN ON YOU'RE ALLOWED TO
DAWN ON YOU? LIKE THIS IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING FOR YOU
WHEN YOU'RE IN COACHING MODE.
THANKS TO A SPORTS CENTER.
NOWADAYS. YOU SEE ALL THESE
GREAT COMEBACKS AND YOU'RE
RIGHT PRAYING THAT IT'S NOT
YOUR TEAM THAT YOU GIVE UP
ONE OF THOSE COMEBACKS TO SO
REALLY WHEN BOTH TEAMS IN T
THE BENCH AT THAT POINT. I
KNEW I KNEW WE HAD BETTER GO
AND REACH THAT FINISH LINE
AND GOD HAS BLESSED US WITH
THE NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP.
AND THEN OF COURSE YOUR
FAMILY BEING THERE, YOU KNOW,
I WAS TALKING ABOUT THIS WITH
JIM NANTZ ON MONDAY BEFORE
THE GAME SCOTT DREW THAT YOU
KNOW, YOU KNOW YOUR BROTHER
MAKING A SHOT DRAWN UP BY
YOUR DAD FOR VALPO AND 1998
IS STILL TO THIS DAY AND
FOREVER WILL BE ONE OF THE
GREATEST MOMENTS IN THE
HISTORY OF MARCH MADNESS AND
NOW HERE YOU ARE WITH YOUR
TEAM.
BUILDING A PROGRAM. THAT WAS
AN ABSOLUTE SHAMBLES WHEN YOU
TOOK IT OVER UNPRECEDENTEDLY,
SO THERE WAS A COVID PROBLEM
FOR YOUR TEAM THIS YEAR AND A
PANDEMIC. THERE WAS A
SNOW AND ICE STORM THAT RACKS
YOUR COACHING STAFF AS YOU
HAD MENTIONED TO US MORE THAN
THE MEMBERS OF THE TEAM WHEN
THAT HAPPENED NOW, HERE YOU
ARE AS YOU MENTIONED THE
FIRST TEXAS TEAM SINCE GLORY
ROAD, TEXAS WESTERN TO WIN IT
ALL WHAT WAS IT LIKE
TO BE WITH YOUR FAMILY AND
TALK ABOUT ALL THIS AFTER YOU
ACHIEVED THE GREATEST MOMENT
OF YOUR COACHING CAREER COACH.
WELL, I CAN TELL YOU WHEN
YOU HAVE THOSE SPECIAL
MOMENTS THOSE GREAT MOMENTS.
THEY'RE NOT GREAT AND SPECIAL
UNLESS YOU HAVE PEOPLE TO
SHARE IT WITH AND ON THE
FLOOR BEING ABLE TO HUG
EVERYBODY THAT WAS A PART OF
IT THAT WAS HUGE AND THEN
AFTER THE GAME BEING ABLE TO
SEE I MEAN SHOOT. YEAH WHEN
FOR FOUR WEEKS RIGHT LEVEL SO
BECAUSE WE WENT FROM
KANSAS CITY TO TO
INDIANAPOLIS AND CAN'T THANK
THE NCAA ENOUGH FOR GIVING US
THE IN NCAA TOURNAMENT. I
MEAN AS A COACH EVERYONE AND
TELL YOU THE YEAR AGO BEFORE
IF YOUR TEAM IS GOING TO THE
TOURNAMENT YOU WENT THAT
LOCKER ROOM AND SAID SEASON'S
OVER THAT WAS REALLY HARD TO
DO BECAUSE MOST MOST MOST
KIDS AREN'T PLAYING IN THE
NBA. THIS IS IT THEY SPEND
THEIR ENTIRE CHILDHOOD
PREPARING FOR THOSE MOMENTS
TO PLAY IN THE NCAA
TOURNAMENT. AND THEN WHEN
THEY HAVE A CHANCE TO GET HIM
AND THEY'RE TAKING AWAY, I
MEAN THAT'S HARD. SO WE GOT
TO THANK THE NCAA FOR ALL
THE SAFETY REQUIREMENTS.
IT'S ALL THE MEDICAL FIELDS
SCHOOLS
FOR PEOPLE TO HUG THEM FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN FOUR WEEKS
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY MY DAD
BROTHER BEN BEN THEREFORE FOR
ALL THE GOOD MOMENTS BAD
MOMENTS. AND WHEN YOU'RE IN
MARCH MADNESS, YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE SOME OF THE BEST
MOMENTS YOUR LIFE. YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE SOME OF THE
TOUGHEST MOMENTS YOUR LIFE
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S MARCH
MADNESS IN 40 MINUTES.
ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN. THE BEST
TEAM DOESN'T ALWAYS WIN.
WE'RE JUST BLESSED. IT WAS US
ON THAT MONDAY NIGHT AGAIN.
JUST YOUR DAD. WHAT DO YOU
SAY TO YOUR FATHER?
LIKE
WHO DID YOU HEAR FROM, YOU
FROM TEXT OR CALL THAT YOU
HADN'T HEARD FROM YOU WHILE
OR DROP A NAME FOR US HERE
WHO MIGHT HAVE REACHED OUT TO
YOU. I MEAN, I MEAN FIRST OF
ALL YOUR I'M ONE OF THOSE
GUYS LIKE IF YOU GET A TEXT
MESSAGE OR EMAIL II GOT TO
GET BACK TO YOU. SO
YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY OVER A
JUST OVER 300 EMAILS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE IN YOUR GET
BACK TO EVERYBODY AND THEN
ONCE YOU GO TO BED THE NEXT
DAY, THEY'RE RIGHT BACK UP,
BUT WHAT IT ALLOWS YOU TO DO
IS YOU HEAR FROM A LOT OF
LIKE THEY WERE ALUMS AND FANS
AND PEOPLE HAVE BEEN THERE
ALL THROUGH THE THICK AND
THIN FROM THE OLD PLAYERS
LIKE DAVID WESLEY BRIAN
SKINNER CHERRY TEGEL TO RG3 TO
LUMPS LIKE THAT JOHN LEE
HANCOCK THE MOVIE DIRECTOR,
WITH WITH OLD I MEAN BACK IN
THE DAY, YOU KNOW WHEN WE
WERE KIDS GROWING UP YOU WHEN
YOU MOVED AWAY YOU DIDN'T YOU
DIDN'T REALLY STAY FRIENDS
WITH PEOPLE BECAUSE YOU
COULDN'T SEE HIM NOWADAYS YOU
GET A LOT OF TEXTING EMAIL
FROM GRAMMAR SCHOOL KIDS THAT
USED TO HANG OUT WITH A JUST
WHAT I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
REMEMBER ME, BUT SO IT'S
GREAT TO RECONNECT WITH WITH
ALL THEM AS WELL. AND YEAH,
I'M SURE WHAT ABOUT THE THE
THE KIDS THAT YOU REFER TO
THAT WERE FIRST IN FOR YOU
AS YOU WERE.
IN THE PROGRAM. OH, THOSE ARE
JUST A GIVEN BECAUSE I MEAN
ALL THROUGHOUT THE SEASON AND
YEAR. WE SEE BEFORE COVID
EVERY SUMMER THE GUYS COME
BACK AND THEN OBVIOUSLY
DURING THE YEAR THEY CAN MAKE
IT TWO GAMES YOU SEE HIM AND
THEN LIKE WHEN WE WON THE
FIRST BIG 12 CHAMPIONSHIP IN
71 YEARS, WE MADE SURE THAT
THEY KNEW JUST HOW MUCH WE
APPRECIATED AND LOVED AND HOW
MUCH THEY PUT IN A
JUSTIN HAWK' DID A GREAT
VIDEO BEFORE
OUR CHAMPIONSHIP GAME AND
SHOWED SOME HIGHLIGHTS OF OUR
PAST PLAYERS AND JUST YOU
GUYS ARE STANDING ON THEIR
SHOULDERS FOR THE FOUNDATION
AND HARD WORK THEY PUT IN TO
GET US TO THIS OPPORTUNITY
AND TO SEE THEIR EXCITEMENT
AND SEE THEIR PRIDE.
THAT-THAT-THAT'S COACHING IS
LIKE PARENTING CHRISTMAS TIME
YOU KIDS OPEN AND PRESENTS.
THEY'RE HAPPY. YOU'RE HAPPY.
YOU KNOW,
WHAT'S THE PRACTICE? WAIT A
MINUTE?
WE DON'T HAVE TO SCOUT. WE
DON'T HAVE THE SCHEDULE. WE
WON THAT CHAMPIONSHIP YES NO
ONE'S GONNA TAKE THAT AWAY
FROM ME MAN. NO ONE WILL DO
THAT AND YOU KNOW YOU'D
MENTIONED AGAIN. WE TALKED
ABOUT IT THE LAST TEXAS TEAM
TO WIN A TITLE AND MEN'S
BASKETBALL WAS THE TEXAS
WESTERN TEEN OF 1966 AND THEY
MADE A MOVIE OF IT AS YOU
KNOW ABOUT COLD GLORY ROAD,
THERE'S A YOU KNOW, AND AND
THE REASON FOR THAT IS IS SO
MANY ABOUT THE STORY AND IT
WAS HISTORIC CERTAINLY
OF ON
I MET AN AMERICAN IN A RACIAL
STANDPOINT, BUT TOUCH LET'S
JUST SAY THAT ANYBODY WAS A
MEN'S BASKETBALL TEAM IN THE
STATE OF TEXAS HAS A MOVIE
MADE ABOUT THEM. WHO DO YOU
WANT TO PLAY YOU IN THE FILM?
HEY GOT YOUR HOLLYWOOD. GOT
ANY ONE UGLY ENOUGH FOR ME,
BUT NO NOTHING.
HE WAS ABLE TO SHARE THAT
TO OUR TEEN JUST THE LAST
TEAM THAT WANTED IT'S AMAZING
WHEN HOW PEOPLE DO FORGET
HISTORY THOUGH AND MAN 19. NO
ONE WAS I MEAN, NONE OF OUR
PLAYERS. OBVIOUSLY, WE'RE
BORDER AND THEN MOST OF US
COACHES WEREN'T BORN DURING
THEN AND THEN WHEN THEY WHEN
THEY SAY GORY WROTE A COUPLE
OF GUYS LIKE THAT WAS REAL
SO IT'S JUST AMAZING HOW
LONG AGO THAT WAS AND IN FOR
STATE THAT HAS HAD SO MANY
GREAT BASKETBALL PLAYERS AND
WE GOT SO MANY
ANY GREAT HIGH SCHOOL TEAMS A
YOU TEAMS COLLEGE JUNIOR
COLLEGE TEAMS, AND I SEE
MORE AND MORE CHAMPIONSHIPS
IN THE FUTURE COMING FROM
THE STATE BUT REALLY HAPPY
FOR THE STATE TO SO COACH
APPRECIATIVE THE CALL ON
MARCH 1ST. LET'S I GUESS
THAT'S NOW WE GOT TO DO IT
EVERY YEAR RIGHT. I MEAN
LUNCH FIRST DOWN THAT'S IT.
AND YOU KNOW, WHAT ON THE
PHONES THOSE CALENDARS ARE
EASY TO JUST MAKE SURE EVERY
YEAR THEY WILL HAVE A MEMORY
OF A MEMORY POP UP ON YOUR
PHONE NOW AND CONGRATULATIONS.
IS REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
THANKS FOR THE CALL. WELL,
PRIEST APPRECIATE YOU AND
THANKS FOR THAT ADVICE ON
MARCH 1ST. ALL RIGHT, BUT YOU
GOTTA YOU GOTTA ASK SCOTT
DREW EVERYBODY. YES INDEED
BLESSED DAY BAYLOR HEAD
BASKETBALL COACH. HOW ABOUT